What do you think of men wearing makeup? Are you dressed up often?
How much time and money do you spend to dress yourself up?
Well, to be honest with you,...
...when I first came to Korea,...
...and saw posters and pictures of men advertising cosmetics,...
...I thought they had to be gay.
But now I know the term "metrosexual" generally applies to...
...heterosexual men with a strong concern for their appearance.
So, as far as I can see,...
...metrosexual men are usually single, young guys...
...with a high disposable income,...
...living or working in the city.
Like most young women,...
...metrosexual men deck themselves out in the nicest clothes.
Let me think of an example here. Ah!
The world famous soccer star David Beckham could be one of them.
He is not only an accomplished star athlete on the field,...
...but also is well-known for both immaculate grooming...
...and a tendency toward nontraditional male clothing.
Back to your question,...
...I spend about 15 minutes to smarten myself up, and less ...
...than 100 thousand won per month on buying clothes and other accessories.
Well, what do you think of those metrosexual men?
Well, I think it's a very good trend.
I love guys having a lot of interest in their appearance.
They are far better than "retrosexual" men,...